am dritten september 2015 fand der 15
wien energie business run statt
1123 firmen entsandten insgesamt 30.000
teilnehmer und teilnehmerinnen zu den
bewerben laufen und nordic walking
also jetzt auch von meiner seite mal ein
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren und wie schon erwähnt ich mich
mit hier ein bisschen oder die vielen
vielen läuferinnen und läufer das
bundesheer stellte mit 1431 teilnehmern
die größte abordnung
die stärke von 4,9 kilometer führte
unter anderem über die meiereistraße die
stadion alle die lust hast straße die
prater hauptallee und den marathon weg
nach einer traffic runde im ernst happel
stadion war das ziel vor dem stadion
erreicht
wichtig ist dabei sein dass das ziel
sehen uns hier die siegermannschaft
nicht gebracht
neuer die siegermannschaft hat sich also
selbst mitgebracht und da ist also sehr
sehr schnell und staat aus dem lager der
orientierungsläufer kerschbaumer ein
bekannter name orientierungslauf
mitglied sind jetzt noch diesen lauf wie
fühlen sie sich jetzt langsam mal
wiederholt als besonders zu laufen ohne
karte und kompass aber darum herumkommen
der spitze niemand es hat alles so
erholt so so ruhig eigentlich
naja es war schon sehr anstrengen
während laufbahn erhalten
nach einer stunde nach dem lauf wird es
wieder reichlich gerne glaube mit
begeisterung wenngleich auch nicht so
schnell wie ich gern würde aber da
erinnern ist es natürlich traumhaft die
große starterzahl
das motiviert insgesamt und im rat es
überhaupt immer schön zu laufen welche
vorarbeiten können wir dazu zählen ja
das ist angefangen von den leibchen
organisieren bis über die dieses area
organisieren über die ganze
infrastruktur aufbauen
das anmeldeverfahren ist ein sehr
umfangreiches verfahren für 1000
schwerte
das alles über zu übernehmen
startnummernausgabe machen wir
geschlossen
ein kleines feines team dieser
unterstützte mich wirklich alle tage
sagen muss das ist um geld zu sparen
ein sehr motiviertes team sie sind zu
hause auch für sport bei der truppe
zuständig er sportler für die vierten
hat bei uns der sport eine sehr hohen
stellenwert bei grunder dienen aber auch
der kader personal
es umfasst die attraktivierung des
kundendienstes und natürlich beim
kaderpersonal fitter körper fitter geist
ist wichtig einfach im regen
soldatenalltag im vordergrund steht die
beste zeit im nächsten sommer das team
event meiner sicht aber ich kann das
spiel das die schöne gegen dass er diese
lauf gegen spielt doch sicherlich auf
alle fälle motivierendes erstens durch
die zuschauer die vielen teilen europas
spielen auf motivation und die gegend
und das wetter war natürlich perfekt
keinen anlauf fällt ja der kommandant
muss natürlich immer von vorne führen so
muss auch hier bei einem solchen lauf
dabei sein sonst kann ich nicht erwarten
von meinen mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern
dass sie ebenfalls dabei sind und hier
das österreichische bundesheer glaube
ich sehr gut repräsentiert habe als
sportbeauftragter und verantwortlicher
für die lehrgänge wie fühlen sie sich
bei so einem großartigen lauf halte hier
ja ich finde es großartig dass das
österreichische bundesheer diesen lauf
organisiert oder zug mit so vielen
leuten hier organisatorisch teilen
mir macht große freude das betrifft ja
meinem job bin ich so viele fitte
menschen personen damen und herren hier
sehe und begleiten darf ja sport für
mich persönlich mein leben lang schon
eine große bedeutung als soldat
natürlich im besonderen und für das
bundesheer freut es mich im besonderen
dass wir heute so viele teilnehmer
stellen das sind die nummer eins in der
firmenwertung und auch in der
teamwertung im spitzensport sind wir die
besten und so soll es auch bei soldaten
seien und wie ging es ihnen heute
persönlich sind sie zufrieden mit ihrer
leistung
nachdem nach der langen anstelle phase
ging es mir gut ich bin zufrieden und
habe eine altersgemäße zeit gelaufen ja
eben erst durchs ziel gelaufen wie
fühlen sie sich
was ich muss sagen es ist ein herrliches
erlebnis mit so vielen menschen in der
frischen luft in körperliche bewegung zu
genießen und ein gemeinsames ziel zu
haben
einmal spaß zu haben und ab bewegung und
frische luft der sport werde dadurch
beim bundesheer also noch populärer
gemacht
also ich muss sagen dass sport ist beim
bundesheer ohnehin nummer eins im
tägigen testbetrieb der druck war auch
in den verwaltungseinrichtungen und man
ist einfach leistungsfähiger und dort
viel mehr freude am tagesablauf
erotisch vor
die ehrgeizigen sportler und
sportlerinnen genossen den fantastischen
rahmen der großartige veranstaltung zu
einem unvergesslichen erlebnis werden
ließ
wahnsinn
highlight
allerdings sorgten
wir vertreten